[Applaudissements]
cher les étudiants chers étudiants de
l'université dauphine chers invités
je suis très heureuse un petit peu
nerveuse haussier d'être avec vous ce
soir et je suis particulièrement
heureuse parce que j'ai fait une année
d'études à dauphine et on venant ici je
me suis rendu compte que c'est aussi un
peu grâce à dauphine que j'ai rencontré
dominique donc vraiment heureuse pas
facile de dire bonsoir après ça merci
mme kane alors moi j'ai pas étudié à
dauphine mais je suis quand même très
heureux d'être là
gta panthéon sorbonne paris 1 alors
pourquoi on est là ce soir
pourquoi nous sommes là on a envie de
vous faire partager quelque chose
une pratique la méditation et plus
particulièrement la méditation de pleine
conscience qui dans sa forme
contemporaine non confessionnelle
pourtant issus des traditions
selon nous selon notre expérience peut
vraiment nous permettre de prendre soin
à la fois de nous mêmes mais aussi
prendre soin du monde donc c'est à cette
exploration qu'on vous invite pendant 18
minutes
commençant à l'exploration première
question exploratoire qui parmi vous
pratique déjà une forme de méditation
pleine conscience ou autre soyez pas
timides dévoilez-vous en tout cas après
ce têt vous pourrez tous levé la main
quand on va vous proposer de commencer
avec une méditation pour laquelle je
vous invite de choisir une position qui
vous aident rester éveillé
et si vous êtes à l'aise de fermer les
yeux et puis de simplement regarder ce
qui se passe
en vous en ce moment quel est votre
météo intérieur les pensées qui sont
présentes les sentiments des sensations
physiques l'échangé rien soyez
simplement ouvert à ce qui est déjà là
et puis je vous propose de porter
intentionnellement votre attention sur
votre respiration focaliser votre
attention sur ce cycle permanent ou un
permanent d'inspirer et d'expirer
essayer un de la sentir
qu'est ce que je sens quand je respire
c'est quoi cette respiration
[Musique]
et si votre esprit par moments on
s'évade votre attention n'est plus
portée sur la respiration ne vous jugez
pas ramener là tout simplement qu'en
quelques instants sur votre souffle
si je vous propose d'élargir ou tous de
votre respiration pour être conscient
dans votre votre corps tout entier comme
si tout le corps respirer regardez
comment est votre expression sur le
visage les sensations se la posent et à
l'intérieur de vous revenez au corps et
revenez dans ce moment présent
puis je vous propose de re ouvrir vos
yeux merci mme kane a tout d'un coup ça
c'est près ce moment musical ce moment
où les choses ont l'air de cette déposer
un petit peu donc continuons notre
exploration
alors qu'est ce qu'on vient de faire
quelque chose d'assez simple on s'est
arrêté plutôt que de nous tourner vers
les technologies et réseaux externes
on s'est tourné vers la technologie
intérieur et les réseaux intérieurs
on a imposé notre attention
intentionnellement sur un objet en
particulier la respiration puis on a
essayé de maintenir cette attention et
une qu'elle nous a invités à le faire
sans jugement donc la méditation de
pleine conscience
c'est simple presque trivial porter son
attention intentionnellement moment
après moment sur l'expérience sans la
juger
c'est simple et en même temps je sais
pas si vous vous quel a été votre
expérience mais c'est parfois très très
difficile à faire
c'est très difficile parce que vous avez
peut-être observer une chose c'est que
l'esprit celui qui pense il n'obéit pas
c'est à dire que vous lui dites de
rester auprès de la respiration
il va faire un tour il va voir ailleurs
il pense au futur il pense au passé il
réfléchit à des choses il commente
l'expérience c'est ce que fait l'esprit
et ça c'est pas un problème dans la
pratique mais c'est peut être un
obstacle il des chercheurs d'harvard
dont objective et ce phénomène et ça va
assez loin parce qu'ils l'ont interrogé
2500 personnes à peu près tout au long
d'une journée en leur demandant de
manière aléatoire dans leur journée est
ce que vous êtes présents à ce que vous
faites et dans 47 % des cas les
personnes ont répondu non
suis ailleurs dans une journée ce pas un
problème mais si on extrapole une
espérance de vie de 80 années ça fait 40
ans de vie dans les nuages
quarante ans de vie à vivre la vie non
pas au contact de l'expérience mais dans
nos pensées donc dans la matrice en
quelque sorte de nos pensées c'est cette
même recherche qui a aussi montré qu'un
esprit qui vagabonde est un esprit est
malheureux ceux-ci point d'un deuxième
phénomène que vous avez peut-être pu
observer que notre esprit est plus
attiré par ce qui ne va pas par les
informations négatives que par les
choses qui vont bien dans les
informations positives
on appelle ça le biais de négativité je
vous donne un petit exemple concret qui
vous parlera peut-être
imaginons un instant que vous postez
quelque chose sur facebook ou sur
youtube sur un thème qui vous tient
vraiment vraiment à coeur et très vite
il y a beaucoup d'amis beaucoup de vos
relations qui on voit des petits coeurs
qu'il ait votre contribution
sauf une personne une personne vous fait
un commentaire assez critique et vous
mes seins dislike de votre contribution
il ya des fortes chances que votre
attention va être happé attirés par
cette une personne qui n'a pas aimé
votre contribution et que vous effacez
presse que les dizaines ou des centaines
de petits coeurs qui sont pourtant aussi
là et selon votre condition du jour la
réaction dans votre corps peut être
assez violent presqu'aussi violents
comme si il y avait un vrai danger vital
assez simplement votre identité qui a
été touchée caisse
le corps quand il perçoit une menace de
cet ordre qu'elle soit vitale ou plus
psychologique il déclenché une
déferlante d'hormones de l'adrénaline de
la cortisol de la noradrénaline tout un
tas d'hormones qui viennent mobiliser le
corps pour qu'ils puissent réagir quand
c'est vital vous êtes poursuivi par un
tigre
il vaut mieux que vous c'est crétier un
peu d'adrénaline pour pouvoir vous
sauver mais quand il s'agit d'un 10 like
sur facebook c'est parfaitement inutile
parfaitement inadaptées or c'est quand
ceux-ci se reproduit beaucoup c'est ce
qu'on appelle le stress chronique qui
créent des désordres dans le corps
jusqu'à des maladies jusqu'à des
comportements l'addiction de distraction
tout un tas de choses qu'on aimerait
éviter
et pas notre souci dans notre société
les stimulations sont à ses multiples
tout à fait tout à fait j'avais un petit
trou là effectivement ce que je voulais
dans les mercis dans les salles a pleine
conscience et la présence au trou donc
dans nos sociétés dans nos sociétés
c'est on est de plus en plus menacé
plutôt psychologiquement même si dans le
monde dans lequel on vit ya aussi des
menaces vitales
force est de le constater il ya de plus
en plus de menaces d'ordre psychologique
pourquoi parce que les rythmes de vie
s'accélère parce que nous sommes
connectés en permanence à tout un tas de
choses
le niveau de relation dans lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir avec
celui qui était mon arrière arrière
grand père quand il promenait les brebis
dans les pâturages où il croisé personne
de sa journée à part les montagnes quand
c'est un peu comme si l'évolution était
en retard un petit peu elle nous a dotés
de mécanismes d'adaptation il ya comme
un retard par rapport aux conditions de
vie que nous avons créés on va voir ce
qui se passe avec la méditation
donc effectivement le cerveau assez
développée pour survive pour détecter
les dangers plutôt que pour être heureux
pour contempler les petites fleurs pour
savourer la vie ça c'est un fait bon
maintenant on a dit rien de bien méchant
et des bonnes chances quand vous a
assommé avec ces mécanismes ces
paradigmes de nos cerveaux un petit peu
archaïque
il est bon temps d'annoncer les bonnes
nouvelles parce qu'il ya un remède à
tout cela un antidote
c'est pour ça qu'on est là pour partager
des bonnes nouvelles qui nous font rêver
avec vous homo sapiens sapiens celui qui
sait qu'il fait nous sommes donc aussi
doté d'autres choses que ce cerveau un
peu archaïque sommes dotés de la
conscience et c'est cette conscience qui
nous permet de voir ce qui se passe
moment après moment de d'être conscient
de reconnaître que ce dislike m'a touché
qu'il a déclenché des effets dans le
corps la mâchoire qui se sait
le coeur qui s'accélère le ventre et qui
se nouent juste le reconnaître de le
voir peut-être même d'observer une foule
de pensée négative jugeant que l'autre
personne ou sur moi qui ont été
déclenchées quand la conscience est
éveillé nous sommes en capacité de va de
reconnaître rester avec d'apprivoiser
sans réagir et le psychiatre à victo
fringues la très joliment et simplement
formuler ce phénomène où ce potentiel
entre le stimulus et la réponse il y à
un espace et c'est dans cet espace que
réside notre pouvoir de choisir notre
réponse c'est dans cette réponse que
réside notre évolution et notre liberté
donc la méditation de pleine conscience
est un entraînement un entraînement de
la tension qui cultive la conscience et
quand on la cultive tous les jours un
petit peu rien de bien méchant
nous développons cette capacité
d'apprivoiser la réactivité de notre
esprit et de vivre pleinement et
peut-être plus joyeusement ce seul
moment qui nous est vraiment donner à
vivre
celui ci
[Musique]
celui ci y compris quand ya un petit
moment de tourmente
comme tout à l'heure quand j'ai eu ce
trou il ya quelques années je voi pub
effondré sur le kana biyik est derrière
en sueur en bilan un communiqué ce qui
t'arrive et tout ça
ce qui se passe là sec ond pouvant être
présent à ce qui se passe en moi
évidemment il ya eu des réactions à ce
moment là mais de rester avec un petit
peu de ne pas perdre pied de pas se
laisser emporter
donc ça fait vraiment partie des
bénéfices que d'entraîner la conscience
de cette manière pour accueillir ce qui
se présente ses bénéfices et prouvez moi
je les ressens je peux vous parler de
mon expérience à la fois dans ma
relation à moi-même dans la relation que
j'entretiens avec les autres et aussi
dans la relation que j'entretiens avec
le monde
toutes ces relations sont beaucoup plus
pacifique en quelque sorte qu' il y a
quelques années où j'étais bien plus en
lutte avec tout ça et puis il ya des
bénéfices que dans le back-office j'ai
envie de dire que la science mesure et
on peut les citer rapidement au niveau
de la plasticité du cerveau les réseaux
de neurones se réorganise avec la
pratique on redéveloppe de la matière
grise à des endroits où on s'y attendait
pas la biochimie du corps ces fameuse
hormone du stress l'adrénaline la
cortisone on régule les taux circulants
de ces hormones en pratiquant ces
impacts le système immunitaire et puis
enfin il ya des études qui montrent même
que cela a des implications sur
l'expression des gènes la manière dont
les gènes s'exprime on est tous dotés
d'un patrimoine génétique mais ce
patrimoine va s'exprimer en fonction de
l'environnement et cette pratique influe
sur l'environnement notre environnement
intérieur en l'occurrence donc on a
parlé des effets du stress à titre
personnel des bénéfices de la pratique
de la méditation
à titre personnel et on voulait faire le
lien aussi entre le stress qu'on
rencontre chacun d'entre nous dans ces
vie frénétique
puis les stress du monde les stress
qu'on inflige à la planète
ce que qu'est ce qui lie à commun entre
eux un comportement des comportements
environnementaux irresponsable entre
l'avidité économique entre la
surconsommation entre une idéologie
radicale
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme un tout entre
tout ça
tout ça sort juste delà de la manière
dont l'esprit humain humains réactif
réagi s'exprime dans le monde essayait
de la manière dont ils se manifestent
imany imaginons un instant un monde où
chaque être humain chacun de ses
coquelicots éphémère que nous sommes
cutif un peu la conscience donc plutôt
que de se laisser tirer dans le
brouillard par la publicité la
surconsommation la violence les
idéologies chaque être humain qui
cultive chaque jour rien de bien méchant
la conscience pour apprivoiser la
réactivité de son propre esprit pour
développer une vision sur soi et sur le
monde plus clair plus libre plus
bienveillant et donc ainsi les deux
guérillas en quelque sorte le mandant
soins et pour contribuer peut-être une
évolution de notre espèce plus positives
mais on vous demande pas de nous croire
évidemment vous demande de faire
l'expérience
voilà qu'un stimuli auditifs travers ce
qui pourrait être perturbante et en même
temps il peut être accueillis donc il
nous reste une petite minute on vous
propose de terminer ce toc avec une
pratique encore juste pour vous
permettre de regarder encore un peu
comment ça fonctionne à l'intérieur donc
si vous en avez l'élan juste fermé les
yeux ou baisser le regard
et connectez-vous de nouveau à skis et
là vous allez remarquer que la
respiration est toujours là qu'elle est
sorti du champ de la conscience mais
qu'elle est toujours là pas besoin de la
contrôler et c'est ce qu'elle a à faire
laissez vous respirez rester avec elle
ne laissez pas votre esprit quitté le
corps ramenés le en douceur sans
jugement
voyez comment
c'est pour vous d'être juste là
maintenant à ne rien faire peut-être
entendre les bruits de l'esprit ces
manifestations mais est resté au plus
bas du corps tout simplement
merci merci à tous de vous être connecté
cette expérience est bonne fin de soirée
si bon soir
[Applaudissements]